coucou c'est le ras-le-bol aujourd'hui
je voulais passer un message à tous les
français parce que voilà j'ai appris que
c'était bientôt vos élections
présidentielles et pour moi je suis
belge hein donc les gens qui essaient de
nous la mettre bien profond je connais
tous maison était pédophile
donc je pense que pour le coup vraiment
vous aider j'ai analysé un petit peu
tous vos candidats alors j'ai compris un
truc très très important cette année
le but c'est pas d'élire un candidat je
vous plaît non alors cette année de
trucks surtout d'arriver à élire le
candidat qui a le plus de chances de
terminer son mandat avant d'aller en
prison alors j'ai analysé un petit peu
tous les candidats en fonction du temps
qu'il leur reste en liberté
françois fillon françois fillon est il
vraiment cet homme malhonnête corrompu
égoïste ce personnage hymne au reiki
veux juste profiter du système se
moquant totalement de la france et des
français
la réponse en images
et alors après françois fillon il
appellait dit les hommes politiques ont
comme responsabilité de montrer le
chemin et ça c'est très bien parce que
françois fillon
il tient toujours parole il va vous
montrer le chemin de fleury mérogis à
tous les délinquants comme lui et ça
c'est du véritable accompagnement des
personnes fragilisées en milieu carcéral
donc merci françois fillon pour ton
dévouement et donc du coup pour
président c'est pas possible
emmanuel macron freud a dit les
personnes qui ont des relations
sexuelles avec des personnes qui ont
l'âge d'être leur mère souvent ça veut
dire que ces premières personnes n'ont
pas beaucoup de goût ou un truc comme ça
en tout cas si jamais bon de refouler
sexualité quand on est homosexuel n'est
pas à l'abri d'ici quelques années
qu'ils se fassent exploser à l'assemblée
nationale et ça c'est vraiment pas bien
emmanuel macron parce que tu sais très
bien qu'à l'assemblée nationale n'y a
jamais personne et donc c'est vraiment
pas cool pour les français marine le pen
arrêtez de dire qu'elle est raciste on a
dépassé ça il faut passer au dessus
c'est un malentendu puisque marine quand
elle était petite elle faisait beaucoup
de ce qui est demandé à son moniteur
monsieur me suivent est ce qu'on peut
faire une piste noire non marine les
noirs c'est dangereux
tu l'aimés sandra quand tu seras grande
marine le pen
génocide sur un malentendu risque quand
même de prendre pas mal d'années à
perpétuité nicolas dupont aignan
j'ai personne n'a jamais entendu ce nom
là tout le monde sait que c'est sarko
qui essaient juste de se représenter
sous un faux nom d'après moi sarko
fillon la mentalité j'adore nairas
jusqu'au bout on se retirera pas même si
c'est très serré me rappelle tellement
mes oncles
qu'est ce qui nous reste mélenchon veut
mélangeant ça pourrait aller il a pas de
mise en examen est alors le problème de
mélenchon c'est que il est certainement
décédées à bas il travaille avec des
hologrammes et les seules personnes
publiques qui travaille aujourd'hui avec
des hologrammes
elles sont au palais des congrès et
c'est david à claude françois et mike
brant mais en chantant qu'on n'a pas de
preuve qu'il ait vraiment envie vaut
mieux pas voté pour lui mais y reste
benoît hamon est bien benoît hamon est
un candidat série compétent intelligent
honnête qui n'essaiera pas de vous
escroquer
regardez plutôt il est très gentil
benoît hamon mais le problème c'est que
c'est toujours pas qu'il a vraiment
passé les primaires il croit toujours
que c'est une caméra cachée benoît hamon
il voulait même pas être président le ps
l'a dit est ce que tu veux partir en
campagne il a dit oui mais il voulait
vraiment partir en week end à la
campagne
un petit week end en champagne ardenne
visiter les châteaux de la loire
faudrait pas publiés tu as passé les
primaires personne ne sait comment
personne n'a voté pour lui aux résumés
de tout ça c'est que ben oui oui vous
vous êtes vraiment dans la merde c'est
ça moi ce que je voulais vous dire il y
a des thalys qui partent tous les jours
de paris nord jusque bruxelles
venez en belgique venait prenez des
trains veut on va se démerder on va vous
accueillir par contre oui ne partez pas
en bateau parce que ça à tous les
migrants vous le diront les bateaux
c'est comme les émissions de tirer la
nonna sa touche très vite le fond et
puis surtout si vous passez par la mer
vous est d arriver en flandre c2c de
l'autre côté c'est les méchants fait si
vous voulez la flandre pour nous les
wallons c'est un petit peu comme le
mexique pour les états unis
sauf que c'est nous qu'on est les
violeurs c'est ça qui fait la
convivialité
nous on n'a pas de président d'un euro
ça sert à rien le seul pouvoir qu'il a
c'est de parler nerfs
d alors qu'à la base il est francophone
et ça nous on s'est dit ok c'est bon on
séduit c'est leur voix c'est de ça que
c'est communiquer avec les deux parties
du pays mais on vous expliquera sa à
votre arrivée on vous donnera des
formulaires tout ça en tout cas d'ici là
faites vos valises et surtout barrez
vous